grazie mille all'ora intanto vorrei dire
che sono un po incazzata perché mi
sembrava una lezione di fisica mi
sentivo un po agli esami di maturità mi
se non passeggiata veramente un sacco
quindi mi devo un attimo casm aree
taglierà ciao a tutti buonasera
grazie per avermi invitato e la puglia è
stupenda
non me l'aspettavo così come anticipato
maria pia
io sono martina dell'ombra marchi per
gli amici martina dell'ombra sul web e
sono buone webstar
la mia frase identificativa e sono una
ragazza normale con un grande sogno
politico ed è esattamente ciò chi sono
perché è molto importante rimanere
fedeli a se stessi e soprattutto ai
propri status di facebook
io vivo a roma
fortunatamente a roma nord che è quel
posto creato per far stare i romani e
ricchi e benestanti al sicuro riparati
dalla zona più periferica di roma sud
dove ci saranno delle persone
estremamente pericolose e fastidiose
come rom immigrati e giornalisti
freelance qualcuno c'è anche qui e chi
vi vedo vivevo con i miei genitori fino
ad un anno fare una bellissima villa con
piscina con loro e con il mio cane
cocaine che è un barboncino nano che in
quanto barboncino nano e molto rigide
molto nero quindi io l'ho pettino tutti
i giorni strappandogli questi capelli
diciamo lasciandolo perché [ __ ] e
riccio fa molto povero quindi non è il
caso di tenerlo così però lui copè non
soffre non si fa male perché si facesse
male direbbe aia invece mi guarda al
massimo a bahia quindi è tutto a posto
invece da una nette sono andata a vivere
da sola in un attico di 180 metri
quadrati che mi ha comprato papa perché
è molto importanti diventare
indipendenti
il mio sogno più grande nella vita è
quello di diventare una persona
importante prestigiosa e riconosciuta e
per questo che decise di diventare una
politica perché i politici sono i nuovi
vip
questo è assolutamente innegabile faccio
un esempio maria elena volti chiaramente
una nuova belen un po più abbondante
oppure trump è chiaramente un nuovo brad
pitt che compensa in ricchezza ciò che
gli manca in bellezza tanto è uguale non
cambia niente
ovviamente ovviamente ho tutte le
qualità per essere una politica di
livello punto primo sono di una famiglia
molto benestante e molto conosciuta a
roma punto secondo mio papa dà da
lavorare ad un sacco in fatto di persone
punto terzo e lo posso giurare qui
davanti a voi ve lo posso anche
dimostrare non sono competente pressoché
in nulla se non sa fare veramente niente
giuro possiamo provare mi può mettere
alla prova non me lo so le cose
questo significa che potrei
perfettamente fare il segretario di
partito o ancora meglio il ministro
quindi sono lanciata su questa strada
molto luminosa per me
certo che come tutte le persone che
vogliono diventare dei politici ma anche
delle persone di livello
se volete diventare importanti nella
vita è molto importante essere persone
culturali ed io infatti sono sto per
culturale perché ha a casa una libreria
che mi ha fatto appositamente un
designer che quest'anno un sacco dei
tagli dove ci sono un sacco un sacco di
libri i libri di scrittori importanti
quelli famosi o alla shakespeare james
lewis ed anti nonna il cantante che
lavora con roma fi ma uno molto più
vecchio poeta mortalmente lazio che è
praticamente morto che tutti devono
conoscere questa cosa di avere tanti
libri la suggerisco anche a voi per
essere persone culturali perché oggi
comunque se non si sa
persone culturali non si viene
rispettati ovviamente avere tanti libri
non significa che li dovete leggere
tutti perché questo può essere molto
molto dannoso vi fa invecchiare come si
vede da qualcuno qua dentro vi fa
imbruttire ma soprattutto vi toglie
tempo tempo prezioso che volete delle
cose molto più importanti come le sante
andare all'aperitivo se non andate agli
aperitivi non troverete mai lavoro e
sarà tutto un disastro
però però ovviamente dovete averli non
dovete leggerli ma dovete fare finta di
averli letti
faccio un esempio ora io ho citato james
lewis in questo mio speech quando
uscirete probabilmente tra di voi
parlerei dedito in face ma tu l'hai
letto non l'eletto ovviamente il no
nessuno l'ha letto perché nessuno lo
legge e una cosa incomprensibile
lunghissima veramente di solito vendono
con la guida alla lettura per cui
figuratevi è illeggibile però dovete far
finta di averlo letto
per fare questo vi potete rivolgere al
più grande strumento culturale della
nostra epoca
questo non il cellulare che serve a
mandare foto porte in realtà quindi non
è il cellulare ma quello che c'è dentro
internet
potete infatti fare riferimento a
wikipedia per l'appunto di nasco anche
adesso ce l'avete in mano prendete
cercate su wikipedia james joyce
guardate velocemente che cosa ha scritto
troverete delle cose che citano mogli
delle winf eccetera
voi memorizzate tutto quanto e poi
quando siete fuori ne parlate sembrerà
che voi effettivamente abbiate letto
questa cosa improponibile
questo è il grande potere culturale di
internet internet effettivamente ha
espanso tantissimo alla cultura l'aveva
molto più democratica la resa molto più
pop
la resa molto più facile la resa anche
un po più ignorante perché comunque su
internet tutti sono dei cultural makers
verdetto bene sì grazie
allora sono tutti di calcio al make up
perché tutti possano scrivere su
internet può iscrivere il presidente
della repubblica come puoi scrivere g
no il barbiere di ostiense e chi è che
decide che quello che scrive il
presidente della repubblica sia più
importante o più figo di quello che
scrive il gene e il barbiere di estense
nessuno è per questo che è stata fatta
una legge sui vaccini ad esempio quindi
questo vi fa capire come tutti quanti
all'interno di internet siano dei
creatori del contesto culturale anche
quelli che non lo sembrano un esempio
gli haters gli haters non solo sono
parte del processo culturale ma hanno
una creatività che supera i confini
dell'umano
vi faccio un esempio da quando sono una
web star
la cosa più bella in assoluto che mi
hanno scritto e vorrei pisciare sulla
tua lapide ve lo giuro è una cosa
secondo me stupenda che supera i confini
della creatività dell'insulto o nei
nuovi orizzonti immaginifici e vuota
l'insulto della sua capacità offensiva
perché oggettivamente non ti puoi
offendere se uno ti dice vorrei pisciare
frullato lapide per vari motivi il primo
che sarai una lapide di base sei morto
sì o se è uno zombie ma non è una cosa
positiva quindi sei morto di base
sarebbe peggio di ciò ma se tipi
sciopero in faccia mentre stai prendendo
la brioche al bar oppure mentre ti
pieghi a raccogliere i 50 euro che ti
sono caduti nella giacomo tipiche in
faccia non è bello quello sarebbe molto
offensivo punto secondo è una persona
che frequenta i cimiteri
quindi ragionando c o è un mormone e
quindi vive in una casetta di legno nel
suo villaggio e vicino c'è un cimitero
che lui può andare regolarmente a
frequentare oppure a un becchino oppure
una terza opzione è un elettore della
lega perché perché gli elettori della
lega in realtà sono molto simili e
mormoni ovvero sono nel 2017 come noi ma
vivono come se fossero nell'ottocento
non sopportano i [ __ ] non so parte dei
[ __ ] non sopportano l'unità d'italia e
non sopportano la grammatica
contemporanea per come l'abbiamo graf
inoltre questa persona sta condividendo
con voi un grave disagio è in continente
è chiaramente in continente quindi un
becchino mormone incontinente leghista
ci ritroviamo di fronte a questo ma fa
qualcosa di più fa qualcosa di molto
umano esprime il suo disagio profondo
solo e soltanto con voi cioè questa
persona che non mi conosce ma mi odia
decide di far venire fuori tutta questa
sofferenza si toglie e pantaloni si
abbassa le mutande se lo tira fuori le
lapidi fra l'altro stanno più in basso
quindi mira anche in alto perché non so
se voi che fra i cimiteri frequentate
voi ma ormai sono tutte alte quindi
cerca di prendere la mira in alto tipo
l'omo ragno e di pescia addosso
dichiarando così il suo fallimento della
sua vita della sua dignità e soprattutto
della sua prostata e lo fa solo per voi
bisogna dirgli grazie io mi sento di
dirmi grazie
perché d'altra parte è a questo
riserviamo noi politici noi guru dei vip
a farci pisciare addosso dalla gente
ovviamente da morti o sul web che
comunque è praticamente la stessa cosa
in modo tale che loro ci possano
riversare addosso una quantità
incredibile di odio totalmente
scollegato sconnesso ingiustificato
senza rendersi conto del motivo per cui
sono realmente arrabbiati e quindi non
si possono davvero ribellare a niente
lasciandoci di fatto il potere di
decidere cosa tutto tutto come se noi
noi vip noi guru noi politici fossimo
gli unici belli in un paese
completamente addormentato che sogna di
pisciare sulle nostre lapidi mentre noi
da svegli costruiamo il mondo nel quale
loro si sveglieranno l'indomani senza
chiedere il loro permesso né tantomeno
la loro opinione perché la loro opinione
del resto è sempre sbagliata d'altra
parte chi è che si fiderebbe mai mio
leghista mormone incontinente becchino
io ti fideresti grazie